hey earlier in this episode we were
talking about hearing loss so we thought
we'd just on the Fly try to test out
some frequencies and see where we're all
at are we prepared to do this no oh
headphones up all the way is that I
wouldn't recommend it
Eduardo you're the one I think who is
captaining this what what have you done
this is kind of unofficial but I just
got curious and I looked up on YouTube
You know here how to how to conduct a
hearing test and so somebody posted a
hearing test that I imagine is going to
play different frequencies you'll hear a
long beep uh I think the
scenarios you have to hopefully hear
these as it gets higher typically people
start to lose their what's your degree
in audio engineering okay
all the doctor I need you guys we all
have to put our headphone monitors to
the 11 o'clock position extra credit for
anybody who can guess what hurts it is
oh you
come on 11 o'clock meaning so just off
off of yeah just left of center okay
okay so here's a quick test first to
make sure that you guys are starting
with the same control
duh yeah yeah okay we hear that now how
loud to kill the president from your
volume
from your volume standpoint did that
feel like too loud you're a little loud
yeah okay so does it just keep going and
keep going it's going to get higher yeah
yeah okay yeah that was just the
beginning I get so nervous I feel like
we're taking a real test we are in a way
we are what could be more real than a
test of our own health and well-being
here we go one one
got it
feel good about that
yeah got it the call you've tried to
make is not
um
okay got it uncomfortable but got it
yeah I hear it and I got it
how many of these are there we're not
even halfway there sure
okay got it I got it T's ready
ugh yep got it still
yeah yeah I'm still here
yeah yeah yeah which one of us can be
the first one to go out I think we all
know it feels like Russian Roulette
yeah got it
these all sound like you suck to me uh
yeah I'm still here yes I still hear him
yeah
this is like the time we said hi back
and forth a bunch of times yeah only
much shittier I got that one okay I've
got this got it I'm feeling good so far
I'm hearing all of these we're not
halfway doing that okay just
Eduardo don't be the voice of Doom and
Gloom you're still in why can't I hear
you
yeah okay still here
yeah yeah yep he's getting up there
yeah yeah but it's quiet is it quiet to
you guys is it quieter I hear it just
fine
this is not a bragging thing I hear that
one I hear it but it's loud as a bell
starting to sound like airplane
background noise
oh oh that's gone that's gone for me too
it's gone okay so we all went out at the
same time none of us are dogs none of
you are dogs no you got all the way to
12 000 Hertz what does that mean
fairness well so the human ear see now
I'm getting two two that's okay that's
okay the human ears is conditioned to
hear up to 20 000 Hertz uh perfect years
anything past 20 000 but as you get
older it goes down from 20 000 to about
16. well now I feel like can you
hear me I can't hear Twenty Thousand
Eduardo how old are you 35. okay can you
hear we dropped out at 12 000 Hertz I
can hear up to about 17
000. so it's still planned for you right
no no I stopped it Eduardo can you hear
this you're fired
everybody else yeah but I wanted better
than you too yeah well first of all
there's about 60 pounds of hair covering
your ears
what to be fair you've got very you've
got very thick locks beautiful hair this
is a compliment oh is it but a very
thick and sort of matted not styled in
any way and then it is a compliment well
it is but you have giant giant curtains
hanging over your ears it's not like on
my ears now but I'm the youngest I'm the
obviously in the best condition
physically wait a minute you didn't take
care of yourself I've known you for a
long time and you partied hearty for
many years yeah but you know you were
into clubs weren't you I was into why'd
you say duck clubs do you always just
say with a D.A whenever you say clubs
whatever if you know D.A send me a DM I
know what the kids are talking about and
I know what time it is what kids are
sending you DMS just so you guys don't
go home concerned I'm gonna play the
higher frequencies now okay here we go
yeah
no and frankly I'm not interested
I heard a little bit wait a minute hear
that wait a minute let me see turn it
off and then turn it and then point and
turn it on here we go ready see if I can
hear the difference
no no I don't hear it either and what's
oh I heard that you could hear it Sona I
could hear it so that was 13 000 Hertz
so I cut out my cut off is 12. about 12
and a half is where you cut off yeah how
am I going to edit this if I can't hear
anything over 12 Hertz
soda will since you're still in this can
you hear
yeah I can hear that
I heard a little bit of that one
she's just lying yeah
I can't hear anything that's 15 000
Hertz wait can you give me 13 again I I
you have you you can hear it here here
we go here's here's 11.5 okay
here's 12.
are you joking
000 I'm gonna turn the volume up to see
if you hear it now okay you this this
will be the true test and then get a get
an audiologist on the phone all right
here we go
oh yeah yeah here's 10.
yeah and what's that I hear eleven
that's eleven yep
hear that all right yeah I hear that
that's we're at 13. but wait you're just
turning up the volume I turned it up
because you guys said a second ago you
couldn't
hear you he's mimicking a hearing aid
correct
hey
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna you
know what I'm gonna do
you know you know what Carly and I are
gonna do Gorly and I are gonna get those
giant ear horns yeah
because you know that you and I would
both love to go to a SWAT to a vintage
store and get really great old you know
they're out yeah I'm gonna get two of
them yeah oh yeah a doctor would be like
here are these like very discreet uh
hearing aids and you'd be like no we
have these giant we have these horns
yeah hey the Kaiser did what
lindenberg accomplished who
yeah all you can do is hear stories from
the early 20th century who has the
vapors
for real though call your audiologist
exactly yeah
is that a concern I mean when you get
below 10 000 Hertz wait but we're not
we're we heard 13. yeah well wait a
minute we heard 13. when she was boosted
up yeah I mean it was way up 13's a she
it is because I think it's crazy that's
oh that's cause for concern
but that's the high frequency we can
otherwise hear like human voices can we
uh can we check urine stream now
I'll let blade take over there but how
mine is like mine is like an Arizona
Creek in uh in in in August and can I
urinate into a death head yeah okay you
lost it it's just dust I lost it how are
we gonna check that you're gonna pee
right now what I think there should be a
little Paddle Wheel that you put in the
urinal it's like a little we can get a
model of a little cottage with a water
yes with a little water wheel and and
there's like a Little Dutch Little Dutch
people that are on the porch and then it
installs in the urinal you pee under the
water wheel and if it plays a nice
little song
then you know that your stream is okay
it's a it's a Grain Mill so if bread
gets made
if little if you if you can if you can
hear loaves of bread you can smell
loaves of bread being baked
and the little people are waving at you
then you're fine different models and
one's a hydroelectric plant and there's
a little village in the bathroom that
the lights all go on yeah
I swear to God this is an idea that
could be marketed it easily installs in
the urinal or your toilet and you check
the power of your stream and you watch
all these cool little lights going yeah
I want toilet bread
yeah and there's a little voice that
goes get your toilet friend get your
urine Brad right here get your urine
Brad no yeast jokes all right that's a
wrap